يؤدي صعود الخليج وخاصة المملكة العربية
السعودية إلى إعادة تشكيل الشرق
الأوسط بالفعل ، ولكن سيكون له أيضًا
عواقب وخيمة في جميع أنحاء العالم.
أنت مخطئ ، الجواب هو
بالطبع المملكة العربية السعودية التي سجلت نسبة
8.7 في المائة ، وسجلت
الكويت في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
نموًا قويًا وكذلك
ما يفسر الطفرة
جيدًا على الرغم من أن الكثير من الأمل في
العالم لا يزال يعتمد بشدة
على الوقود الأحفوري أوكرانيا  أدت الحرب والعقوبات
ضد روسيا إلى تقليص
أهمية موسكو في أسواق النفط والغاز العالمية
بالإضافة إلى دولتين من
أكبر الدول المنتجة للنفط في العالم ، تخضع
إيران وفنزويلا أيضًا
للعقوبات ولديهما بنية
تحتية نفطية قديمة ومتدهورة
تنتج أمريكا الكثير من النفط والغاز ولكنها
لا تزال تستورد  كميات كبيرة
نتيجة لذلك ، يعتمد العالم الآن تمامًا
على عدد قليل من البلدان في
الخليج الفارسي كموردين ثابتين وموثوق بهم
للنفط والغاز ، ومن
المرجح أن تستمر هذه الظروف
خلال العقد المقبل ، وإذا فعلوا ذلك ،
فستشهد الخليج واحدة من أكبر  تدفقات
الثروة في التاريخ بالفعل ، أفادت التقارير أن
صناديق الثروة السيادية الأربعة الرئيسية لهذه
البلدان قد جمعت ما
يقرب من ثلاثة تريليونات دولار في الأصول
بزيادة قدرها 42 في المائة على مدى العامين الماضيين.
تريليوني دولار بحلول عام 2030 مما يجعلها
الأكبر في العالم في
المستقبل المنظور ، وستكون هذه أكبر
تجمعات لرأس المال على هذا
الكوكب.
العواقب الاقتصادية لهذه الثروة في
كل مكان حولنا.
أن المملكة سعت إلى شراء
امتياز سباقات الفورمولا 1 بأكثر من 20
مليار دولار ، فقد جذبت ربما
نجم كرة القدم الأكثر شهرة في العالم
كريستيانو رونالدو للعب مع أحد
فرقها مقابل 200 مليون دولار
سنويًا ، فهي تقوم باستثمارات ضخمة في
الألعاب عبر الإنترنت  على أمل أن
تصبح لاعباً رئيسياً في هذا الفضاء ،
انظر حولك إلى الفنادق الفاخرة للفرق الرياضية المرموقة
في أوروبا والعلامات
التجارية ذات الطوابق ، وقد ترى وراءهم
مالكي الجولف العرب كما قال لي أحد وزراء الجولف لقد
قمنا ببناء الكثير من
البنية التحتية في بلادنا.
يأتي الآن نقدًا لاستثمار
هذه الطفرة في الثروة التي أعادت تشكيل
الشرق الأوسط ، حيث كان اللاعبون الكبار والمهمون
تاريخياً في
المنطقة مهيمنين في يوم من الأيام. مصر العراق سوريا
لأسباب مختلفة من الفقر.
هو أن المملكة العربية
السعودية على وجه الخصوص قد حققت
تحولًا استراتيجيًا ضخمًا في سياستها الخارجية في
سنواته الأولى في السلطة ، استخدم
ولي العهد الأمير محمد بن سلمان ، الحاكم الفعلي للمملكة ،
ثروة بلاده
بطريقة فجة ومتعجرفة حاول
بطرق مختلفة للضغط أو الإطاحة
النظامان في قطر ولبنان والأردن
أثناء خوضهما حربًا ساخنة في اليمن وحربًا
باردة مع إيران لم يثمر أي منهما عن
أي ثمار ، فقد
حدث مقتل جمال خاشقجي في 2018 أيضًا في هذه الفترة
في السنوات القليلة الماضية على النقيض من ذلك
يبدو أنه قد نضج للإصلاح.  العلاقات
مع قطر والأردن إعادة
العلاقات الدبلوماسية مع إيران والسعي
بنشاط لإبرام اتفاق سلام في اليمن ،
تعمل دول الخليج جميعها على تعميق
علاقاتها مع الصين التي تعد الآن
أكبر عميل في المنطقة في عام 2001 ، كانت تجارة المملكة العربية السعودية
مع المملكة الوسطى تزيد
قليلاً عن أربعة  مليار دولار حول
عُشر تجارتها مع الغرب
في عام 2021 ، كان ذلك يزيد بنحو 87 مليار دولار
عن العلاقات الاقتصادية المشتركة بين الولايات المتحدة والاتحاد الأوروبي التي
تنمو بسرعة ،
حتى أن صحيفة واشنطن بوست تفيد بأن
الصين واصلت بناء
منشأة عسكرية مشتبه بها في الولايات المتحدة.
لا
تسعى الإمارات العربية المتحدة والمملكة العربية السعودية والخليج إلى الطلاق مع الولايات المتحدة ،
فهم يريدون علاقات اقتصادية وثيقة مع الصين
وعلاقات أمنية وثيقة مع أمريكا ،
فهم يريدون أن يكونوا قادرين على التعامل بحرية مع
الجميع بما في ذلك روسيا إذا كنت تريد أن
ترى إلى أين ذهب الروس  هربًا من
العقوبات الغربية ، قم بزيارة دبي حيث
ستستمع إلى اللغة الروسية أكثر من العربية في
بعض الفنادق التي
تربطهم علاقات متنامية مع الهند ،
بل إنهم يبنون روابط جديدة مع إسرائيل ، حيث
ترغب معظم الدول في اتباع
سياسة تسمح لهم بحرية
اختيار الأصدقاء في الغرب والشرق  بما
يتناسب مع اهتماماتهم
إذا استمر محمد بن سلمان في المسار الذي يسير فيه
الآن ، فمن المؤكد أن المملكة العربية السعودية ستكون
قادرة على إدارة قانون التوازن هذا.